[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys und Murats Welt!
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Wir stehen jetzt gerade bei uns hier im Garten.
Und ich muss sagen,
wir sind gerade so an der letzten Ernte.
Also die letzten Tomaten wurden geerntet.
Mein Chili wächst noch.
Aber ich muss sagen,
dass mein Garten jetzt wohl oder übel
leider in den Winterschlaf verfällt.
Ich weiß aber auch, dass,
wenn ich jetzt hier perfektere Bedingungen hätte,
also dass ich praktisch mehr Wärme hätte,
ein Glashaus hier drumherum,
>> MURAT: Mehr Sonne.
>> SALLY: mehr Sonne,
würde ich hier sogar es wirklich noch schaffen,
dass meine Erdbeeren,
die jetzt auch bis vor Kurzem noch gewachsen sind,
meine Tomaten und alles,
was hier Sonne und Wärme und Licht und Wasser braucht,
eben auch länger wächst.
Kann ich natürlich jetzt hier in meinem Garten nicht machen.
Aber vielleicht habt ihr es ja schon
in der einen oder anderen Story mal mitbekommen.
Denn Murat und ich,
wir nehmen euch ja wirklich bei allem mit,
wir zeigen euch, was uns bewegt, was uns begleitet.
Und wir gehen jetzt tatsächlich
unter die Landwirte, also wir werden Landwirte.
>> MURAT: Ja, wir machen was richtig Revolutionäres.
Und das Thema beschäftigt uns seit drei Jahren.
Und seit drei Jahren
– wer mir auch in den Storys folgt auf Instagram,
weiß, dass wir hier an etwas ganz, ganz Heißem dran sind.
Das ist wirklich etwas Revolutionäres,
was die Landwirtschaft revolutionären kann in Deutschland
und auf der ganzen Welt.
Weil wir haben ein System entwickelt,
man nennt es die Aquaponik,
wo jedem helfen könnte
und auch Hilfe zur Selbsthilfe finden könnte.
Das heißt, wir können Menschen helfen,
ihr Gemüse regional das ganze Jahr über anzubauen.
Wir könnten die Problematik mit dem Wasser haben.
Weil momentan ist es auf der Welt überall so:
wenig Wasser, wenige landwirtschaftliche Flächen
stehen zur Verfügung.
Und wir haben hier einen Problemlöser gefunden,
wo wir in den nächsten Jahren wirklich was erreichen könnten.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Und wir würden euch das mal gerne vorstellen,
was wir da vorhaben.
Und es ist so genial,
dass wir auch anderen Menschen
in anderen Ländern helfen könnten damit.
>> SALLY: Ja. Und vielleicht noch eins vorweg:
Also man muss dazu sagen,
wir machen jetzt der Landwirtschaft hier in der Region
oder auch überregional keine Konkurrenz.
Es ist eher eine Ergänzung und eine Optimierung.
Und ich würde sagen,
wir nehmen euch jetzt einfach mal mit.
Wir reisen ganz kurz,
aber die Reise ist gar nicht so lang.
Denn wir bleiben in Waghäusel
>> MURAT: Genau.
>> SALLY: und fahren einfach nur zwei, drei Kilometer.
>> MURAT: Und das ist ja nur regional.
Und das, was wir machen, das kann jeder machen.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Und das wollen wir euch jetzt zeigen.
>> SALLY: Komm, wir gehen.
>> MURAT: Ja.
So.
>> SALLY: Wir sind jetzt hier immer noch in Waghäusel,
nämlich ungefähr zwei Kilometer Luftlinie
von unserem Zuhause entfernt.
>> MURAT: In einem kleinen Waldstück
von einem Freund von uns.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Und hier hinter uns seht ihr auch schon ein Gewächshaus.
Aber das ist kein normales Gewächshaus,
sondern hier betreiben wir die Aquaponik 2.0.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Und zwar ist die Aquaponik
– das kennt man ja im Prinzip auch schon.
Da sind jetzt wir nicht die Erfinder davon,
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: aber wir Aquaponik einfach ein bisschen optimiert.
Und zwar ist eine Aquaponik die Zusammenkunft
oder einfach der Zusammenschluss zweier Berufe,
nämlich zu einen die Aquakultur, das heißt die Fischzucht,
>> MURAT: Genau, der Fischbauer.
>> SALLY: der Fischbauer, und die Gemüsekultur,
nämlich
>> MURAT: Der Gemüsebauer.
>> SALLY: die Hydroponik.
Und wenn man die Aquakultur
und die Hydroponik zusammennimmt,
gibt es die Aquaponik.
>> MURAT: Genau. Und wir haben dann
noch einen draufgesetzt.
Und warum Aquaponik 2.0?
Weil wir trotzdem noch mit Erde arbeiten.
>> SALLY: Bei der Aquaponik ist es nämlich so,
dass die Fische und Pflanzen voneinander profitieren.
Sie sind also in einem ökologischen geschlossenen Kreislauf,
in dem eben nichts verloren geht.
Die Ausscheidungen der Fische,
die dienen den Pflanzen als Dünger.
Und die Pflanzen reinigen das Wasser für die Fische.
Damit das klappt, helfen Bakterien.
Sie wandeln nämlich das hochgiftige Ammoniak,
also aus den Exkrementen der Fische, in Nitrate um.
Die Nitrate dienen den Pflanzen dann als Nährstoffe
und werden über die Wurzeln
durch das nährstoffreiche Wasser aufgenommen.
Das Nitratwasser ersetzt sozusagen komplett die Erde.
Die Pflanzen nehmen die Nitrate auf
und klären somit auch wieder das Wasser.
Und dieses kann dann ganz sauber
wieder an die Fische weitergeleitet werden.
Das Wasser wird also immer wieder benutzt
und bleibt in diesem geschlossenen Kreislauf.
>> MURAT: Eigentlich eine ganz einfache Geschichte.
>> SALLY: Hm.
Das ist sozusagen die Aquaponik.
>> MURAT: So einfach, wie es eigentlich jetzt
in der ganzen Bebilderung war, ist es natürlich nicht.
Und wir bauen wirklich gerne Pflanzen an.
Ihr folgt ja unseren Videos
und ihr wisst ganz genau, Garten ist bei uns was Heiliges,
>> SALLY: Ja, das ist auch unsere Leidenschaft.
>> MURAT: ist unsere Leidenschaft.
Und wir bauen das auch gerne an.
Aber eine Aquaponik,
da braucht man ein bisschen Erfahrung.
Und natürlich, ich habe das mal in einer Sendung gesehen,
war dann so überrascht vor drei Jahren
und habe mir gesagt
– ich habe mal ein bisschen mehr darüber recherchiert.
Und beim Recherchieren im Internet
bin ich eigentlich immer auf eine Person gestoßen.
Eigentlich egal, welchen Artikel ich gemacht habe,
bin ich immer auf diesen Peter Winkler gestoßen.
Immer Peter Winkler.
Peter Winkler macht ein Entwicklungsprojekt
in verschiedenen Ländern,
war schon in Afrika, war schon in der Türkei,
hat so Aquaponik-Anlagen aufgebaut.
Und den habe ich dann eigentlich kontaktiert.
Und der hat sich dann wochenlang nicht gemeldet,
bis ich ihm zu Hause aufgelauert habe
und ihm von meinem Projekt erzählt habe.
Weil wir möchten ja
– uns ist ja nicht langweilig.
Also wir haben genug zu tun jeden Tag
mit dem, was wir gerade machen.
Aber es gibt auch Dinge, wo man die Welt verändern kann.
>> SALLY: Ja, ich meine, bei dieser Aquaponik
geht es ja nicht nur darum, dass wir zu Hause,
wir als Team und als Waghäusel
Gemüse haben oder Fisch haben,
sondern es geht ja darum,
man kann ja damit wirklich die Welt verändern.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Du kannst ja im Prinzip Lebensmittel dort anbauen
und dort erschaffen,
wo die Menschen sich nicht selber versorgen können.
>> MURAT: Genau.
Und sozusagen habe ich dann,
wie gesagt, den Peter angesprochen,
ob er uns da helfen könnte bei diesem Riesenprojekt,
das Ding auch zu skalieren
und es auch in die Welt zu tragen,
euch das auch zu zeigen,
wie man das zu Hause selber machen könnte
und damit einen Beitrag zum Umweltschutz macht
und natürlich auch zur Ökologie.
>> SALLY & MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Und deswegen stehen wir hier,
wie gesagt, vor diesem Gartenhaus, vor diesem
– wie heißt denn das?
>> MURAT: Gewächshaus, Sally.
Ja, kann mal passieren.
>> SALLY: Und deswegen stehen wir jetzt hier vor diesem...
Deswegen stehen wir jetzt hier vor diesem Gewächshaus.
Und dieses Gewächshaus, so, wie es hier steht,
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: ist sozusagen unsere Testanlage.
Das heißt, es wird experimentiert, es wird ausprobiert,
welches Gemüse kann man anbauen,
wie viel kann man anbauen, wie ist der Ertrag.
Und so was kann man wirklich
bei sich daheim im Garten aufbauen,
aber eben auch zum Beispiel in Entwicklungsländern.
>> MURAT: Genau. Und hier war noch nie ein Kamerateam,
auch nicht Galileo,
war auch noch nie hier,
weil es topsecret ist.
Und, wie gesagt, seit zwei Jahren steht diese Anlage hier.
Wie die Sally gesagt hat,
hier machen wir die krassesten Experimente,
natürlich ohne Tierversuche, ohne Tierleid.
Habe ich auch recht?
>> SALLY: Ja. Und der Peter,
der ist schon seit über zehn Jahren,
muss man auch dazusagen, in der Aquaponik tätig.
Das heißt, der hat wirklich die Erfahrungswerte.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ich würde sagen, kommt,
wir gehen jetzt einfach mal rein, oder?
>> MURAT: Ja.
Nach dir.
>> SALLY: Hallo Peter! Wir sind da!
>> PETER: Hallo Sally!
>> SALLY: Da ist er, der Peter, mitten in den Pflanzen.
>> PETER: Hi Murat!
>> SALLY: Dürfen wir reinkommen?
>> PETER: So. Ja, kommt rein.
[Musik]
>> MURAT: So. Das ist er jetzt, der Peter Winkler.
Und zwar ist er der Cristiano Ronaldo der
Aquaponik-Branche
oder Borussia Dortmund der Aquaponik-Branche.
Ich bin kein Bayern-Fan. Deswegen.
>> SALLY: Kein Fußball!
>> MURAT: Ja, kein Fußball. Entschuldigung.
So. Den Peter...
Der Peter ist eigentlich
studierter Theologe und Sozialarbeiter.
Das passt natürlich prima zu mir.
Mit Sozialarbeitern habe ich oftmals zu tun gehabt
in meiner Jugend.
Und Theologe ist
– wichtig ist immer, dass Gott einem beiseitesteht.
Also habe ich genau zwei Fliegen
mit einer Klappe geschlagen,
indem der Peter uns zugesagt hat,
dass er uns bei unserem Projekt hilft,
diese Aquaponik-Anlage zu bauen.
Diese Aquaponik-Anlage, die wir jetzt hier haben,
ist eigentlich eine ganz, ganz simple Anlage,
also wirklich low budget.
Das heißt, diese Anlage könnte sich jeder leisten.
Keiner
– ich meine, jetzt wird keiner so eine große Anlage bauen,
aber wir haben hier ungefähr ohne das Zelt jetzt hier
Investitionskosten von ungefähr 3.500 €.
Und wir haben es extra so gemacht,
dass es eine Anlage ist,
die man überall auf der Welt
herstellen könnte oder aufbauen könnte.
Das hat verschiedene Hintergründe.
Der Peter hat schon mit vielen Studenten,
mit vielen Universitäten diese Anlagen aufgebaut,
hat auch schon Entwicklungshilfe
in Kenia, in Indonesien geleistet.
Und er weiß, was er hier macht.
Und meine Intention ist es
oder unsere Intention ist es natürlich,
Aquaponik noch bekannter zu machen
und auch etwas zu erzeugen.
Peter, deine Intention ist, Aquaponik
– was ist dein Ding, was ist dein Ziel,
was du erreichen möchtest mit der Aquaponik?
>> PETER: Also mein Ziel ist,
dazu beizutragen, dass weltweit, wenn möglich,
ja, Lebensmittel nachhaltig produziert werden können
durch die Aquaponik,
>> MURAT: Vor Ort.
>> PETER: sprich, Fisch und Gemüse.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> PETER: Ja, genau.
>> MURAT: Ja. Und das hat uns,
diese zwei Gedanken haben uns
eigentlich zusammengebracht und diese Intention.
Und ich denke mal,
jetzt können wir den Zuschauern mal zeigen,
wie so eine Aquaponik-Anlage eigentlich aussieht
und was unsere Aquaponik-Anlage so besonders macht.
>> PETER: Dann, würde ich sagen, fangen wir doch
bei den Fische an, oder?
>> MURAT: Ja.
Kommt mit.
Hier eigentlich auf eine ganz, ganz einfache Art und Weise
– das sind Kunststofftanks
und hier drin befinden sich Fische.
Hier können wir eigentlich
jeden beliebigen Süßwasserfisch nehmen.
Momentan haben wir den Südafrikanischen Wels,
weil der eigentlich
– wie soll ich sagen? –
ein ganz, ganz einfacher Fisch ist.
Und der wird auch riesengroß.
Ihr merkt es schon
– jetzt würde ich die mal gern füttern.
Jetzt seht ihr mal, was jetzt gleich passiert.
Achtung.
Ui!
Wahnsinn, oder?
Da kriege ich jedes Mal einen Schock.
Wahnsinn! Wie so Saugroboter.
Wenn der Carlyle jetzt hier reinkommt und er singt,
dann kommen die von alleine schon hoch, gell?
>> PETER: Ja, stimmt.
>> MURAT: Und das Besondere an dem Fisch ist
– es heißt, Aquaponik ist eine Fischzucht.
Wir haben sie jetzt in ganz einfachen Behältern drin.
Später werden das richtige große Bottiche.
Man kann ja verschiedene Fische reinmachen.
Zum Beispiel Tilapia kann man reinmachen.
Man kann sogar Forellen reinmachen.
Wie gesagt, dieser Fisch,
dieser Südafrikanische Wels ist sehr, sehr anspruchslos.
Und die werden riesengroß.
Und die kann man später natürlich auch verarbeiten.
Die kann man dann zu Fischfrikadellen verarbeiten, zu
– was gibt es noch, Peter?
Was haben wir schon alles probiert?
>> PETER: Brotaufstrich...
>> MURAT: Brotaufstrich.
O Mann! Das hört sich jetzt blöd an,
einen Fisch zum Brotaufstrich machen.
Das sollte man eigentlich nicht so sagen.
Auf jeden Fall, diese Fische brauchen wir.
Weil die helfen uns bei dieser Gemüsezucht.
Und es ist unglaublich,
wie viel Fisch man eigentlich damit züchten kann.
Wir reden hier wirklich von Tonnen,
die wir nachher haben.
Und da könnten wir jetzt eine ganze Gemeinde damit
nur mit so einem Fisch wirklich ernähren in Afrika.
Das wäre zum Beispiel möglich.
Das heißt, man könnte in Afrika
– Hilfe zur Selbsthilfe nennt sich das –
so eine Anlage aufbauen,
dass die Leute wirklich in dem Dorf in Afrika
genug Fisch haben, sich zu ernähren,
genug Gemüse haben, sich zu ernähren,
und so viel produzieren,
dass sie sogar das auf dem Markt anbieten könnten.
Und, wie die Sally schon erklärt hat,
diese Fische, die hier drin jetzt leben,
die machen Ausscheidungen
und diese Ausscheidungen werden dann
mit Pumpen durch diese HT-Rohre
– diese HT-Rohre bekommt man
eigentlich überall im Baumarkt.
Deswegen, diese Anlage ist so einfach gemacht,
dass man sie überall in Afrika, in der Türkei,
in Indonesien, in Kenia, überall aufbauen könnte.
Genau.
So. Das Wasser, das schmutzige Wasser
– oder die Ausscheidungen von diesen Fischen –
wird jetzt hier durch diesen Filterturm,
sage ich es mal so, Peter, wird das, wie gesagt...
>> PETER: Kann man so sagen.
>> MURAT: Genau.
Das nennt sich auch
– Nitrifizierung nennt sich das.
>> PETER: Genau.
>> MURAT: Und jetzt fließt das ganze Wasser
aus diesem Fischbecken hier rein.
Und hier wird dann dieses Ammoniak
– das kennt ihr eigentlich, dieses Ammoniak.
Das riecht ein bisschen nach Pipi, richtig?
>> PETER: Ja. Das ist ganz ätzend.
>> MURAT: Ganz ätzend.
>> PETER: Ja, hochgiftig.
>> MURAT: Genau.
Das wird umgewandelt in Nitrat.
Und Nitrat ist genau das,
was die Pflanzen für ihr Wachstum brauchen.
>> PETER: Genau.
>> MURAT: Richtig?
Und ihr seht, wie einfach diese Anlage eigentlich ist.
Hier sind so Kisten aus dem Baumarkt
und da drin befindet sich so ein Tongranulat.
So.
Das nitrathaltige Wasser
fließt dann durch diese HT-Rohre
unter den Pflanzen durch
und die Pflanzen nehmen sich einfach diese Nährstoffe
und fangen an zu wachsen.
Richtig, Peter?
>> PETER: So kann man es verkürzt sagen. Ja.
>> MURAT: Genau.
Und jetzt kommt eigentlich das Besondere.
Normalerweise bei einer Aquakultur oder einer Hydrokultur
arbeitet man ohne Erde.
>> PETER: Richtig.
>> MURAT: So.
Aber wir haben uns den Spaß gemacht
und zwar: Wir lassen die Pflanzen trotzdem in der Erde drin.
So sieht das aus.
Das sind diese Plastikbecher, die ihr überall kennt.
Und das Tolle ist wieder,
diese Plastikbecher bekommst du überall auf der Welt.
Und hier ist ein Granulat drin und Erde drin.
Und das ist der Unterschied zwischen einer reinen Hydrokultur,
wie wir es jetzt momentan
– oder zu einer reinen Aquaponik-Kultur,
wie es normalerweise ist.
>> PETER: Aquaponik wird eigentlich erdfrei angebaut
und wir machen das mit Erde.
>> MURAT: Genau.
Und diese Erde haben wir übrigens selber produziert.
Das ist wirklich unser Gemüse,
was wir auf den Kompost geworfen haben,
was dann zu Erde geworden ist.
Das heißt, es ist eigentlich
ein komplett geschlossener Kreislauf, den wir hier verwenden.
Und was wir nicht machen
– auch das ist ganz, ganz wichtig zu erwähnen.
Wir nehmen unseren deutschen Landwirten
oder den österreichischen Landwirten nehmen wir nichts weg,
weil wir zu einer Zeit produzieren,
wo die in Deutschland und in Österreich
gar nicht produzieren könnten.
Das heißt, Sachen, die wir zum Beispiel aus dem Ausland
von weiter weg importieren müssten,
können wir regional überall,
im Dorf, in der Stadt, neben dem Supermarkt,
anpflanzen und anbauen.
>> PETER: So ist es.
>> MURAT: Am besten eignet sich übrigens dafür
Blattgemüse natürlich.
Es ist alles möglich.
Es ist wirklich fast alles möglich,
nur manchmal fehlt halt die Sinnhaftigkeit.
Ihr seht da hinten zum Beispiel unsere Tomaten.
Wenn jetzt das ein Gärtner sehen würde,
würde er jetzt die Hände
vor dem Gesicht zusammenschlagen.
Und zwar müssten wir die schon längst mal ausgeizen.
Aber was machen wir?
Wir geizen nicht aus, wir reizen es aus
und zwar bis zur Unkenntlichkeit.
Wir lassen alles wachsen und gucken, was funktioniert,
was für Krankheiten kommen.
Und das sehen wir wirklich schon.
An den Blättern kann man schon oftmals sehen:
>> PETER: Ja.
>> MURAT: Ist hier ein Mangel an Nährstoffen oder nicht?
Warum entsteht dieser Mangel?
Haben wir zu wenig Fische, haben wir zu viel Fische?
Haben wir zu viel Nährstoffe, haben wir zu wenig Nährstoffe?
Stimmt was mit der Erde nicht?
Stimmt was mit den Pumpen nicht?
Das sieht man wirklich,
wenn man mal über die Pflanzen drüberschaut.
Du bist ja eigentlich so was wie der Pferdeflüsterer,
– habe ich recht? –
nur der Pflanzenflüsterer.
So.
Und ich kenne mich da inzwischen auch richtig aus.
Ich bin schon ein richtiger Crack.
Man kann schon sagen, ich habe zwei grüne Daumen.
Und du hast eine grüne Hand sozusagen.
>> PETER: Und eine Flosse.
>> MURAT: Und eine Flosse?
Ach, eine Flosse hast du auch schon. Stimmt. Genau.
Und wenn wir es schaffen,
diese Anlage in groß zu bauen
– und zwar groß heißt riesengroß
und zwar wirklich die größte Aquaponik-Anlage Deutschlands
und zwar nicht nur deutschland-, sondern europaweit,
in Helmstadt-Bargen.
Hier haben wir ungefähr 80 Quadratmeter.
Mit diesen 80 Quadratmetern,
so, wie wir es mit dem Peter zusammen aufgebaut haben,
könnten wir eine fünfzehnköpfige Familie in Afrika
komplett das ganze Jahr wirklich ernähren
und diese Familie könnte diese Produkte
auch auf dem Markt anbieten.
Habe ich recht, Peter?
>> PETER: Ja, richtig.
>> MURAT: Dann zeigen wir noch,
was wir für tolle Idee noch haben
und vor allem was für verschiedene Pflanzen
wir jetzt schon anbauen.
Und wir können mal zeigen, wie das funktioniert.
>> PETER: Einen Teil können wir zeigen.
>> MURAT: Genau.
>> PETER: Ein anderer Teil ist schon durch.
>> SALLY: Okay,
das war jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen viel Info auf einmal.
Und ihr könnt euch vielleicht gar nicht so richtig vorstellen,
was Peter, Murat und ich euch erklären wollten.
Im Prinzip entsteht hier gerade unsere Testanlage
und die steht jetzt auch schon seit Längerem.
Und mit dem Peter zusammen
entwickeln wir gerade das System
und machen einfach eine Probe.
Das heißt: Was wächst gut?
Was kann man super ernten?
Was schmeckt besonders gut.
Und wir möchten einfach
Obst und Gemüse anpflanzen und ernten
und daraus zum Beispiel auch andere Lebensmittel herstellen.
Das heißt, wenn wir jetzt zum Beispiel Basilikum anpflanzen,
kann man daraus ein supertolles Pesto machen.
>> MURAT & Sally: Ein eigenes Pesto
>> MURAT: aus Waghäusel oder aus Bayreuth
oder aus Duisburg,
aber alles regional.
>> SALLY: Eben da, wo die Aquaponik-Anlage steht.
Hier wächst das Obst und Gemüse
und direkt nebendran kann man es auch verarbeiten
und dann zum Beispiel auch
– und da kommt es jetzt wirklich
auf den Handel auch drauf an, muss man sagen –
im Supermarkt zum Beispiel anbieten.
Denn wir brauchen im Prinzip ja auch einen Partner,
der uns da unterstützt, muss man sagen.
Das heißt, der Handel muss bereit sein,
die Ware dann auch anzunehmen,
damit sie eben auch an alle kommen kann.
>> MURAT: Und das ist ja mehr als bio.
Also wir verwenden ja auch keine Pestizide,
wir tun ja nicht düngen,
wir haben auch keine Traktoren, die die Sachen ernten.
Das ist wirklich
– das wird gepflügt.
Das ist eine geniale Geschichte.
Wir nehmen keinem Bauern etwas weg.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Und die Überlegung war auch:
Wenn zum Beispiel gerade
Saison von Spinat ist in Deutschland,
dann produzieren wir keinen Spinat,
dann produzieren wir etwas anderes.
Und wenn es im Winter keinen Spinat mehr gibt,
dann produzieren wir Spinat.
Wenn es im Winter keine Erdbeeren mehr gibt
aus der Region,
dann produzieren wir Erdbeeren.
Wir verarbeiten das alles.
Wir haben hier ganz, ganz coole Gewürzmischungen,
ein cooles Basilikum-, ein Pesto Genovese.
Wir könnten ein Tomatenpesto machen.
Wir könnten so viele Produkte erzeugen
und alles vor Ort.
Und das können nicht nur wir hier Deutschland machen.
Wir könnten so eine Anlage in Afrika aufstellen
>> SALLY: Ja, überall.
>> MURAT: in einem Dorf
>> SALLY: Überall auf der Welt.
>> MURAT: und wirklich überall auf der Welt
und Menschen, die sich von selbst nicht ernähren können,
diese Grundlage bieten, dass sie sich selbst versorgen,
dass sie Produkte machen
und diese auf den Märkten anbieten.
>> SALLY: Ja. Und man kann eben auch Dinge,
die bei uns gar nicht so wachsen
oder auch nicht angepflanzt werden,
eben auch direkt aus der Region bekommen,
das heißt Ingwerwurzel, Kurkuma.
Man kann ganz tolle Gewürzmischungen machen.
Aber es geht nicht mal mehr nur um das Gemüse,
sondern man kann nämlich auch den Fisch verarbeiten
und so dazu beitragen, dass eben
nämlich das komplette System sozusagen verwertet wird.
Und ich zeige euch jetzt mal ein paar Dinge,
die man mit dem Fisch machen kann.
>> MURAT: Also das ist ganz krass.
Es ist wirklich schade, dass ihr jetzt nicht probieren könnt.
Und zwar haben wir mit einem Freund von uns zusammen,
der selber Fischwirt ist und auch mit Fisch handelt,
mit dem haben wir aus unserem Fisch Produkte gemacht.
Und die Produkte sind so wahnsinnig,
dass du nicht mehr den Unterschied erkennst,
ob da jetzt Fisch,
– oder jetzt im Normalfall wäre es ja Schweinefleisch –
ob Schwein drin ist.
Das heißt, wir haben hier schon Produkte
und wir würden gern jemanden was probieren lassen.
Leider kann der Güni jetzt gerade nicht,
weil er auf der Baustelle ist.
Und jetzt haben wir uns einfach Max geschnappt.
Max macht eine Ausbildung bei uns
und er darf sich einfach nicht beschweren.
So.
Und das Coole ist, Max kommt aus Herzogenaurach.
Das ist im Bayrischen.
Und was isst man in Bayern am liebsten?
Leberkässemmeln.
Das heißt, wenn ich euch sagen würde,
wie ein Fleischkäse schmeckt,
kann ich es euch nicht sagen,
weil er meistens aus Schwein ist.
Ich habe ihn aber auch schon aus Geflügel gegessen.
Und jetzt wollen wir einen echten Bayern mal fragen:
Wie schmeckt unsere Leberkässemmel aus Fisch?
Okay?
>> SALLY: Das ist keine Semmel.
>> MURAT: Ja, halt Leberkäs.
>> SALLY: Wie schmeckt der Leberkäs?
>> MURAT: Leberkäs.
So. Max, komm mal her.
>> SALLY: Ich hoffe, er mag den Leberkäs.
>> MURAT: Und passt auf. Das ist jetzt auch nicht gefakt.
Er hat davor echt noch nicht probiert.
Und, Max, mir wäre es trotzdem extrem wichtig,
weil wir können die Rezeptur wirklich noch verändern,
>> MAX: Okay.
>> MURAT: bitte probier das.
Und ich habe dir jetzt leider gesagt,
dass es aus Fisch ist.
Jetzt probier es mal wirklich. Sag mal, wie es schmeckt.
>> SALLY: Also letzte Woche hatten wir es da
und haben es probieren lassen und haben es keinem gesagt.
>> MURAT: Wir wissen schon, wie es schmeckt.
>> SALLY: Und dann...
>> MAX: Und da ist es niemandem aufgefallen?
>> SALLY & MURAT: Nein, da ist es keinem aufgefallen.
>> MURAT: Und es ist wirklich unser Fisch
aus unserer Aquaponik-Anlage.
Max, jetzt tu...
Weißt du, das...
Weißt du, ich komme mir gerade selber blöd vor,
weil die Zuschauer denken, dass es vielleicht
– dass es gefakt ist.
>> MAX: Das ist doch kein Fisch.
>> MURAT: Doch, es ist. Ohne Spaß, das ist Fisch.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Probier noch mal. Bitte.
Und es ist wirklich der absolute Wahnsinn!
>> SALLY: Also ich muss auch echt dazu sagen:
Als der Hans-Peter uns das vorbeigebracht hat,
hat er gesagt: "Probiert mal! Probiert mal! Das ist Leberkäs."
Dann habe ich gesagt: "Ich esse keinen Leberkäs.
Ich esse kein Schwein."
Und er: "Doch! Probier mal! Probier mal!"
Dann habe ich gesagt: "Hans-Peter, ich esse es nicht.
Das weißt du doch."
Da hat er gesagt: "Das darfst du essen. Jetzt probier!
Da ist kein Schwein drin."
Und dann habe ich es probiert.
Ich meine, ich kenne den Geschmack nicht,
aber ich finde es megalecker.
>> MURAT: Hm.
Und jetzt sei mal ehrlich.
>> MAX: Das ist kein Fisch.
Also ich glaube, wenn man es weiß
und man dann so darüber nachdenkt,
merkt man vielleicht so ganz leicht diesen Nachgeschmack,
ganz minimal.
Aber ansonsten so vor allem beim ersten Biss,
hätte ich jetzt nicht gedacht, dass es Fisch ist.
>> MURAT: Ist krass, gell?
>> MAX: Also ich hätte gedacht wirklich, das ist Leberkäs.
>> MURAT: Jetzt pass auf.
Jetzt haut es dich noch mal ganz um.
Pass auf. Jetzt ohne Spaß.
Also du siehst jetzt keinen Unterschied,
ob es jetzt ein Rind-, Schwein- oder ein Fischwürstchen ist.
So.
Das ist jetzt ein Wiener.
>> MAX: Okay.
>> MURAT: Okay, jetzt probier mal.
Und das ist aus Fisch.
>> MAX: Ganz? Komplett?
>> MURAT: Nein, probier es. Iss es mal ganz, ja.
Ich habe seiner Mutter versprochen, dass ich auf ihn aufpasse.
Also, liebe Mama, mach dir keine Sorgen.
Dein Sohn ist bei uns in guten Händen.
>> SALLY: Wir füttern ihn gut durch.
>> MAX: Man denkt auch nicht, dass es Fisch ist.
Es schmeckt anders...
>> MURAT: Ja! Es ist Wahnsinn!
Es ist...
>> MAX: Es schmeckt ein bisschen anders,
aber man denkt nicht, dass es Fisch ist.
>> MURAT: Es ist der Wahnsinn!
Es ist der absolute Wahnsinn!
>> SALLY: Ich finde es halt vor allem der Wahnsinn
– ich bin jetzt nicht so der Fischfan, muss ich echt gestehen.
Und ich esse Fisch eigentlich nur,
weil ich dann das Gefühl habe, ich esse was Gesundes,
Omega 3 und so weiter.
Und deswegen gibt es bei uns auch nicht Fisch
oder nicht oft oder fast gar nie Fisch.
Und meine Kinder wachsen leider dann auch so auf,
muss ich sagen.
Aber so kann ich den Fisch auch an die Kids
und an mich selber bringen.
>> MURAT: Jetzt stellt euch mal vor,
in Afrika bauen sie unsere Anlage auf,
die wir entwickelt haben,
und jetzt können sie ein ganzes Dorf mit Fisch und Fleisch
oder halt mit Fisch wirklich ernähren,
Produkte daraus machen
und du hast kaum Wasserverbrauch.
Jetzt, Max,
die Würstchen, weißt du, wie die heißen?
>> MAX: Mhm.
>> MURAT: Weiß du, wie diese heißen?
Canabossi.
Canabassi.
>> SALLY: Wie?
>> JOSH: Cabanossi.
>> MURAT & SALLY: Cabanossi.
>> MURAT: Mein Gott, he!
So.
Wenn wir das Produkt machen,
dann nennen wir es ganz anders, okay?
Cabanossi. Okay.
>> SALLY: Dann nennen wir es Murat.
>> MURAT: Jetzt probier mal die Wurst bitte.
Jetzt ohne Spaß. Probier es mal.
Natürlich weiß ich nicht, wie Cabanossi schmecken.
Aber, wenn Cabanossi so schmecken,
dann schmeckt es echt lecker. Ohne Spaß.
>> SALLY: Mmh! Schmeckt gut.
>> MAX: Das heißt bei uns Pfefferbeißer.
>> MURAT: Das ist ein Pfefferbeißer!
Ich habe einen Pfefferbeißer gemacht!
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MAX: Schmeckt lecker.
>> SALLY: Also das ist jetzt nur eine kleine Auswahl
an Dingen, die uns so im Kopf herumschweben.
Man kann natürlich viel mehr machen,
Aufstriche, Fruchtaufstriche,
Brotaufstriche, Gemüsedips,
Frikadellen.
Also es gibt wirklich eine große Range an Dingen,
die wir in unserem Kopf haben,
die wir jetzt demnächst alle umsetzen werden.
Aber ich würde sagen,
wir springen jetzt wieder zurück zum Peter.
>> MURAT: Ja, aber warte mal noch ganz kurz.
Ich muss noch was sagen.
Im Lebensmittelhandel ist es ja so:
Man sucht dauernd neue Dinge.
Die letzten Jahre waren es bio, vegan.
Und glaubt mir, das ist die Zukunft,
Aquaponik, das heißt ein geringerer Wasserverbrauch,
weniger Fläche, die man braucht zum Anbauen.
Und man kann solche Produkte regional machen.
Also wir haben hier keine Massentierhaltung.
Wir brauchen das Schwein nicht mehr,
muss ich gerade sagen,
und können hier wirklich Fleischkässemmeln machen,
also wirklich einen richtig coolen Fleischkäs nur aus Fisch
oder auch die Cabanossi oder die Wiener.
>> SALLY: Oder Gewürzmischungen.
>> MURAT: Ja, oder Gewürzmischungen.
Es ist unglaublich, was man da alles machen kann.
Schön wäre es, wenn diese Produkte natürlich im Handel
gelistet werden.
Und es wäre eine tolle Geschichte.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Jetzt gehen wir wieder zum Peter.
>> MURAT: Genau. Und lasst uns das alles revolutionieren.
Hier sehen wir natürlich verschiedene Salatsorten,
die wir angepflanzt haben.
Hier haben wir Endiviensalat.
Hier haben wir einen Kopfsalat.
Hier haben wir einen
>> SALLY: Lollo rosso.
>> MURAT: Lollo rosso, das hört sich an
wie ein Hauptdarsteller von einem Schmuddelfilm,
ist aber ein ganz, ganz toller Salat.
Und man kann verschiedene Dinge wirklich,
wie Blattgemüse, komplett das ganze Jahr über anbauen.
Ziel wäre es aber auch,
diese Produkte direkt vor Ort zu verarbeiten.
Das heißt, wenn man ein cooles...
Wenn man Basilikum hat,
– Basilikum geht zum Beispiel super in der Aquaponik –
was könnten wir aus dem Basilikum machen?
>> SALLY: Pesto.
>> MURAT: Pesto Genovese.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Genau.
>> SALLY: So sind wir ja auch auf die Idee gekommen
mit unserem Olivenöl,
>> MURAT: Genau.
>> SALLY: weil wir ja gesehen haben,
dass in Fertigpesto kein Olivenöl verwendet wird,
sondern Sonnenblumenöl.
Da wissen wir jetzt auch besser warum.
Weil Olivenöl im Kühlschrank fest wird
und Sonnenblumenöl eben nicht.
Aber, Peter, du hast ja hier jetzt gerade Salate drin.
Du hattest ja auch schon Rucola und alles, nicht?
Wir haben ja im Prinzip schon
ganz viele verschieden Pflanzen und Gemüsesorten durch.
>> PETER: Genau.
>> SALLY: Was mich jetzt
oder vielleicht die Zuschauer jetzt eher interessieren würde:
Wie lang hat jetzt zum Beispiel
der Basilikum da vorne gebraucht,
bis er so weit gewachsen ist?
Also wie ist er praktisch von null bis...
>> PETER: Der Basilikum geht relativ schnell.
Aber ich würde jetzt lügen,
wenn ich genau die Tage sagen würde.
Wie viele es waren, müsste ich nachschauen,
weiß ich jetzt auswendig nicht.
Aber er geht schneller wie im Freiland.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Das ist ja auch der springende Punkt, dass es schneller geht.
>> MURAT: Wenn man so was zum Beispiel
in Afrika machen würde,
dann bräuchten wir zum Beispiel keine Beleuchtung mehr.
Weil Pflanzen brauchen ja wirklich Licht zum Wachsen.
In Deutschland brauchen wir das.
In Afrika wäre das gar nicht nötig, richtig, Peter?
>> SALLY: Da hat man ja längere Tage.
>> PETER: Wir haben jetzt ja Anfang November
und da geht ohne Licht
bei bestimmten Pflanzen eben nichts mehr.
Und in Afrika die haben lange Tage,
die brauchen nicht zusätzliches Licht.
>> MURAT: Genau. Die könnten es sogar ohne Ding machen,
ohne so ein Zelt zu machen,
sondern wirklich unter freiem Himmel, vielleicht nur mit einem
>> PETER: Schattennetz.
>> MURAT: Schattennetz. Genau.
Das wäre auch alles möglich.
>> PETER: Ja.
>> MURAT: Und es gibt unglaublich viele Dinge,
die man mit der Aquaponik nachher machen könnte.
Und ja, wir probieren einfach aus
und gucken, was noch alles möglich ist.
Schnittlauch haben wir auch schon gegessen.
Richtig lecker!
Und es gibt sogar Zucchini.
Richtig?
>> SALLY: Nee, das sind Auberginen.
>> PETER & MURAT: Auberginen.
>> MURAT: Mein Gott! Mein Gott!
>> PETER: Zucchini ist auch kein Problem.
>> MURAT: Ja, Zucchini ist – genau.
>> SALLY: Aber ich meine, das ist ja jetzt alles Regionales.
Ich meine, du probierst ja auch gerade Dinge aus,
die hier eigentlich nicht wachsen.
>> PETER: Exotisches. Ja, genau.
>> SALLY: Ingwer und
>> PETER & SALLY: Kurkuma.
>> PETER: Ja, da sind wir gerade an einem Versuch.
>> SALLY: Okay.
>> MURAT: Jetzt stellt euch mal vor,
ihr würdet Kurkuma aus Waghäusel bekommen
oder Ingwer aus Waghäusel
und da ist...
>> SALLY: Das wäre schon cool.
>> MURAT: Und stellt euch mal vor,
jede Ortschaft in Deutschland hätte eine Aquaponik-Anlage,
jede hat eine,
also wirklich jedes Dorf, jede Stadt tut sich selbst versorgen.
Das heißt wiederum weniger CO2-Ausstoß.
Das heißt, die Dinger
werden nicht mehr in der Gegend rumgefahren,
es kommen keine Lkws mehr aus Spanien oder aus Italien,
weil jeder sein eigenes Gemüse herstellt.
Das wäre was Gigantisches.
>> SALLY: Und weniger Lebensmittelverschwendung,
weil alles ganz frisch auf den Tisch kommt.
>> MURAT: Genau.
>> SALLY: Länger haltbar.
>> PETER: Genau, das optimale Community-Konzept.
>> MURAT: Genau. Und das andere
– man muss noch viel weiter denken.
Und zwar jetzt stell dir mal vor,
es kommt nur so viel Gemüse, wie auch gebraucht wird.
Das heißt, du tust nur
– du gehst rüber und sagst: "Hör mir mal zu.
Spinat ist gerade"
– im Supermarkt Spinat ist gerade alle.
Und dann rennt einer in die Aquaponik-Anlage,
zupft den Spinat und legt es wieder ins Regal rein.
Aber ist doch perfekt.
Das heißt weniger Foodwaste.
Das wäre auch eine geniale Geschichte.
Und das alles aus Waghäusel
oder später aus Helmstadt-Bargen.
Weil da entsteht eigentlich unsere große Anlage.
Und diese Anlage ist voller Hightech.
Es ist wirklich voller Hightech.
Weil da geht es dann wirklich um die Skalierbarkeit,
darum, viel zu produzieren natürlich,
dass es natürlich auch finanziell Sinn macht,
muss man ehrlich sagen.
>> PETER: Genau.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Also ihr seht, hier wird noch fleißig getestet,
es wird angepflanzt.
Und hier am Ende der Kette sozusagen
kommt ja auch dann wieder das saubere Wasser
zurück zu den Fischen
und das Ganze beginnt von vorne.
Also nichts wird verschwendet.
Und was wir hier im Kleinformat machen,
beginnt jetzt bald in Helmstadt-Bargen im Großformat.
Und da fahren wir jetzt mal zusammen hin, okay?
>> MURAT: Ja, die größte Aquaponik-Anlage Europas.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Kommt, wir nehmen euch auch mit.
Jetzt sind wir hier in Helmstadt-Bargen.
Das ist ungefähr
>> MURAT: eine halbe Stunde von uns entfernt.
Ja. Hast du dich jetzt größer gemacht?
Und ich sitze halt...
>> SALLY: Hast du jetzt einen Tritt benutzt?
>> MURAT: Nein, ich sitze im Loch.
So.
In Helmstadt-Bargen sind wir
und zwar eine halbe Stunde von uns aus Waghäusel entfernt.
Hier ist übrigens auch die Firma Dekoback,
>> SALLY: Ja, da sind wir deswegen
>> MURAT: der Rüdiger, ein paar Straßen weiter.
>> SALLY: recht oft.
>> MURAT: Und die Gemeinde Helmstadt-Bargen
hat uns die Möglichkeit gegeben,
diese Anlage hier aufzubauen.
>> SALLY: Ja. Deswegen haben wir es auch
nicht in Waghäusel gemacht.
Da gab es halt irgendwie keine Fläche mehr.
Und jetzt hier in Helmstadt haben wir...
>> MURAT: Schade für Waghäusel natürlich.
>> SALLY: Ja, es ist echt schade,
>> MURAT: Ja, schade.
>> SALLY: muss man schon dazusagen.
Und hier in Helmstadt haben wir jetzt die Fläche bekommen
und dürfen unsere Aquaponik-Anlage aufbauen.
Momentan ist das Ganze noch beim Bauantrag,
also der Bauantrag wird jetzt gerade gestellt.
Also so soll das Ganze ja in Zukunft dann aussehen.
Gezeichnet ist es schon und geplant.
Und dann, denke ich, kann es
in wenigen Wochen/Monaten losgehen.
>> MURAT: Ja.
Bis Mitte/Ende nächsten Jahres soll die Anlage stehen.
Wir entwickeln halt jetzt solang die Produkte,
reden mit verschiedenen Lebensmittelhändlern.
Das heißt, wir werden mit allen in Gespräche kommen,
mit allen Lebensmittelhändlern.
>> SALLY: Wäre natürlich cool, wenn dann die Lebensmittel
eben auch in den Lebensmittelhandel kommen,
>> MURAT: Genau.
>> SALLY: muss man dazu sagen, ja.
>> MURAT: Und es wäre auch schön,
wenn so eine Anlage, wie wir sie jetzt machen,
vielleicht überall in Deutschland sein könnte.
Das heißt, wir könnten es schaffen,
Lebensmittel bei uns in der Heimat herzustellen
und immer regional
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: das ganze Jahr über.
>> SALLY: Damit die Tomaten eben
nicht mehr aus Spanien kommen müssen
oder aus Holland oder aus anderen Ländern,
sondern wirklich direkt vor Ort
>> MURAT: Genau.
>> SALLY: ohne Transportwege.
>> MURAT: Ja.
Nachhaltig,
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: ohne Pestizide, ohne gar nichts.
>> MURAT: Wäre das eine geniale Geschichte?
>> SALLY: Das wäre richtig cool.
>> MURAT: Und wir werden dann richtige Landwirte?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Und Fischzüchter?
>> MURAT: Und Gärtner?
>> SALLY: Alles zusammen.
>> MURAT: Alles zusammen.
Und Produzenten von Lebensmitteln.
>> SALLY: Und das auch noch.
>> MURAT: Ganz cool!
Viele, viele Arbeitsplätze natürlich.
>> SALLY: Ja, auf jeden Fall.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Und das ist ja jetzt erst nur der Anfang der Reise.
Das heißt, ihr könnt uns gerne weiterhin begleiten.
Und sobald es neue Infos und Updates gibt,
werden wir euch darüber berichten.
>> MURAT: Ja. Und mit dem Peter werden wir dann gucken,
was wir noch im Ausland erreichen können
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: und anderen vielleicht helfen könnten,
das genauso zu machen.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Damit es überall auf der Welt regionale Lebensmittel gibt.
>> MURAT: Und auf dem Weg dahin
werden wir noch viele Sachen
neu erfinden und gucken.
>> SALLY: Auf jeden Fall.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Also bis zum nächsten Mal!
>> MURAT: Bleibt dran! Tschau!
[Musik]